so welcome back everyone uh right before
we have uh our last talk for the day
Nicole will make a brief announcement
about a social event here at Simons yeah
um hey everyone so this is about music
night happening tonight 5:30 pm room6
which is just on this floor if you walk
in a circle you'll find it uh we all get
together and play music it's fun you
don't have to have any music um
experience to come to music night so
5:30 today room 116 if you want to
join
okay so welcome back everyone uh I'm
pleased to now introduce the last
speaker of the day who's Lee rhods
visiting us from Yahoo um talking about
uh engineering insights from engineering
sketches for production and using
sketches at scale and you might have
noticed in previous talks I was running
around and handing mics to people who
had questions but uh now that there are
people who are looking out for people
who have questions so just raise your
hand and mic will come
here
okay thank you very much gani it's a
real honor to be here and uh as an
engineer who uh loves mathematics but
doesn't understand half the mathematics
that you guys do um it's a real honor so
you may wonder why why in the world am I
at a conference like this
um the part of it is that
um we're really passionate about
sketching and um our real mission in in
fact um and before I start there the um
the project that we're part of is called
Apache data
sketches and I started this project uh
at Yahoo back in about 2011
2012 um because we were
having um severe computational time time
problems um just counting noses uh just
counting uniques uh over very large data
sets it would take many many hours if
not days okay to do these computations
so I was asking the question there's got
to be a better way and so I started
reading the literature and and uh
started getting really really interested
in the whole sketching concept so part
of a again our mission is to design and
build sketches that address common
computationally difficult problems for
systems that must must process massive
data um and these sketches have to be
easy to use by systems engineers and
programmers most of the time when I give
a talk it's really the audience is
engineers and programmers who've never
heard of a sketch right so a lot of it
is convincing them that in fact having
approximate Solutions can be extreme
useful so far uh in our library we have
focused on sketches that are backed by
published research by many of you have
proven error
Behavior Uh single pass sublinear and
their size growth mergeable thus thus
parallelizable uh without increasing
error and practical to implement and
have good data Independence
properties now so that really brings me
to the talk so I'm not going to talk
about the library per se I'm not going
to talk about the sketches we've built
instead I want to sort of back the
journey up and say what have we learned
in this process of building sketches
over the last 10 plus
years
um building them and making them ready
for production and uh using sketches at
Large Scale so so that's really um what
I want to talk to you
about the first Insight is that a lot of
our data is highly
fragmented with many
dimensions and that leads to um a power
law distribution this one here was one
that collected uh some years ago has
like nine orders of magnitude in terms
of the number of unique IDs on the the
uh x- axis and seven or so orders of
magnitude in terms of the number of
groups now what is a group well I did a
little sort of a brief SQL up here if
you have streams that have an ID and
some n Dimensions associated with that
ID then first you Group by ID that's
Group by the set of set of
Dimensions okay and then you count the
number of distinct IDs in that
group okay and then the y- AIS is the
number of
groups that have the same count of
unique IDs and then you plot X and Y
okay so you can see the top top left
corner up here uh we have 10 million
groups that have exactly one user
ID and at the other end of this chart
you have close to 7 or
800 million users in one
group That's a classic power
law uh distribution problem and of
course it now I I ploted this is actual
data off off of one of our systems that
was I think just a few hours of data um
gives you a sense because the number of
actual events that's fed into the system
is in the billions and these and so this
is already a reduction in terms of in
terms of groups now this has a number of
consequences when our our data coming in
has this kind of
property first
for um for small
cardinalities we need good
accuracy when we're often when we're
building a sketch and building the proof
we think about in the limit right so if
the number of events is in is very large
goes to much you know infinity or large
number then you can prove uh what the
error behavior is but in
fact we really need good accuracy all
the way down to
one um the other Insight is the storage
of this long tail can be significant fra
fraction of the overall storage and so
some of the things we've had to do is
build some techniques for effectively
compression uh on the very storage in so
we're storing sometimes many tens of
Bill millions of sketches and we built a
system that actually Pro over a billion
sketches every day so we really have to
pay attention to the storage costs and
um the propagation of
those of course this requires that the
sketch must start very small and grow
sublinearly and ultimately end its
growth hopefully some can end their
growth at a fixed size or as they cap
out so to speak they grow very very very
slowly the sheer size of the data and
the high degree of
fragmentation of course leads to
parallelization there's no way really to
process these massive data sets without
having multiple Machines working in
parallel so this merge ability property
is critical for all of our
sketches um and not only must be
mergeable but if you do merge them you
don't you don't really lose accuracy in
that
process here's an example of a sketch
it's not ours this is the TJ sketch if
you've ever familiar with it I'm not
saying it's a bad sketch some people use
it quite
successfully but we FedEd a sort of a
pathological stream of
inputs and you can see what's going on
down here the very bottom I'm sorry the
very bottom of the graph is about
[Music]
uh
what 10 minus 2 is 100th of a per % uh
and the top keep switching on and the
hop top is 100% so the sketch at the as
you're feeding it more and more inputs
the sketch can't figure out what's going
on they can't can't
establish um what what the um actual
result should be so it's has it's
clearly
gyrating and not under very much control
control the very the blue curve which is
uh the bottom here uh is our KL float
sketch this is a quantile sketch um and
is zero error now here and comes up and
normalizes it some median value
here
so so you say well so what most people
don't care about the small counts well
let's see let's let's take a point like
a million which is 10 the 6 down here
here and that's sort of where this other
sketch sort of
stabilizes and let's go back here and
see what that represents so suppose we
had a power law distribution like this
and I have a
million
events that corresponds to maybe
groups and so this because of the power
law the total number of groups at this
at down here is maybe 4
500 out of 3.7
million which means using that sketch
I'd only be able to effectively analyze
with reasonable accuracy a very tiny
percent of the overall data
set so this is why understanding this
this effect is um is really important
now so we took the same sketch and FedEd
a different
um different set of data that was
uniform
random here it behaves a little better
uh the accuracies uh at the upper left
is about 50% and it slowly improves and
lo and behold it even gets better than
um than our
sketch but there's this is an empirical
algorithm there's no proof of error
there's no guarantee there's no
statement of how you know accurate it
can be
um and it is input sensitive it's in
sensitive to the order of the data and
the distribution of the data so
um not what I would consider a very
reliable sketch at least how how we view
it now it may well be that this
particular sketch has improved since we
did all this study a couple years ago um
but the lesson here the Insight is
sketch accuracy independent of the data
distribution and its order is very
important and this um here I'm going to
show growth strategies I talked about
sublinear growth in
size and this uh is two families of
sketches it's our hlll sketches which
exist in um we say h four six and eight
and that that is with respect to the
number of bits per bin in the hyper log
log sketch are most of you familiar with
the hyper log log
it's it's been out there for a long time
U so our our smallest sketch is hl4
where you have only four bits per Bend
and then we have also a six and an eight
and um so our Theta sketch which I'll
talk about a little bit later is much
larger it's a bottom K
sketch and it's H maybe 10 size 10 times
larger than the um H
sketches um but notice that during the
early part of the growth it's very
smooth it's clearly
sublinear in in
size but the interesting thing is the
Theta sketch in the end is much larger
but during the whole growth phase it's
only twice as large as the hll
sketch so it says it's it's really very
economical as it as it grows uh in size
this one down here I put in um these are
all spe the Theta these up here are all
specified with the same accuracy um but
the Ed of four sketch is uh here I've
specified it with a log K of four as
well so that means it has only 16 bins
uh so it's extremely tiny uh and you can
see it it uh tops out at about 48 bits
the
entire hll
array is only eight
bytes so it's a very compact very
compact
sketch and here's another family of
sketches where we have again engineered
the the growth strategy to be uh to pave
very smoothly so these are our kll
sketches
and it as you can see it grows slowly
and then as it sort of TAPS out at the
top it grows even slower still so even
with h what we got here 100
million looks like like
uh three trillion no three Bill three
billion inputs it has a size of only
three
kilobytes so it's it's very economical
in its size
[Applause]
now let's talk about the flag fous
sketch which
2007 question
yes I think you said earlier you like
cared about the growth rate of this I
was curious like why do you care about
the growth rate of the sketch rather
than just like the final size that it
hits because you want it to be small if
you've got millions of sketches with
only one entry you don't want them so
basically for every one of these groups
you have a different sketch is that for
every one of these like groups that you
had plotted like several sides ago you
have it's an a different distinct
element sketch is that
right I think of it this way you've got
millions of sketches and they have uh
are representing cardinalities that
range from one to the millions right now
in our power law distribution it turns
out we have millions of sketches with
only one entry
now you don't want to consume you know
kilobytes of space just because you have
one
entry right so again you want a a
gradual
growth strategy for sketches as they
grow from very small up to some finyl
size or or limiting does that make
sense now if you take the uh
flaget uh fous sketch
um 2007 and just implement it straight
from the
paper don't do anything
special and then um you capture as you
are now what we've done here is we've
got 10,000 trials and we've identified a
number of points across this x-axis
where we want to take measurements lots
of them so visually you hardly see
them so for it you know so we'll give it
10,000 trials with a cardinality for uh
inputting a cardinality of say four then
8 160 32 okay and then we'll figure out
what the quantiles are for at each of
those
steps so this rep this the lower curve
represents the fifth uh uh percentile
this is the upper one is the 95th
percentile of all
all 10,000 trials at that
cardinality so the cross-section is is
really sort of a it's a gaussian okay
when you have that that many now there's
two two interesting things going on here
um that you only really see if you do
this kind of characterization of the HL
sketch one is this Spike and it's really
quite famous it's called the flaglet
error Spike it's because is because in
the uh in Flash's paper he uses two
estimators one is a poison
estimator that has high airor on on the
right and it gradually comes down and
then goes close close to zero error for
very low counts and then his hll
estimator which his whole paper is
really about has low error for high
counts and then starts its error goes
starts to go up at some point and
becomes unacceptable that's why he added
his poison estimator into the mix so
that he can get reasonable error
Unfortunately they don't quite meet up
exactly in fact one goes up like this
the other goes up like this you have
this Gap okay in the Middle where you
have this this high air and it occurs
quite regularly about two and a half
times whatever K is the sketch which is
the number number of
bends so what do we do about
this
um this by the way we considered so oh I
was point out one one other little
anomaly here this little Spike
here it's at the uh fifth percentile and
it clearly goes
[Music]
below this by the way represents one one
rsse or one standard deviation below the
mean and clearly exceeds the if you say
your error guarantee probabilistically
is plus or minus one standard deviation
it goes
below any guesses what's causing
that
this is a
quiz any
guesses okay turns out
the when the entropy of the input stream
which is basically the Precision of the
input stream is higher than the entropy
of the sketch itself and so this was a
log six log log case1 16 sketch which is
65,000
bins and you can add a few bits because
then in the hlll sketch we're recording
a number of leading or trailing zeros
okay but the input stream has got these
are like
64-bit hashes right so huge amount of
entropy and so if it happens that in the
input stream
there is a unique value and these are
all uniques coming
in has a value that hits the same bin
and with the same or less number of
leading zeros in it the sketch will
reject it saying it's a duplicate but in
fact it's
not and that's exactly what's what's
happening happening down here it only
happens at the fifth percentile this
early
um because the probability of
at at that percentile you're only have a
few values I mean this is like 80 80
some odd cardinality of 80 or so so if
all of a sudden instead of
80 all of a sudden the sketch disregards
one it
shouldn't it BEC 79 so it's less than
what it should be which is 80 so so it
it goes low and we can you can actually
model this phenomenon it's natural
anytime you have higher entropy coming
in then you have entropy of the of the
Precision of the sketch you can have
this kind of situation so this is kind
of bothering we'd like to fix this we'd
also like to like to fix the U the error
Spike okay so our atel sketch is
actually three sketches in one
um first when it first starts up uh with
zero entries it has a a little list
sketch which just keeps the first
eight
values it
sees doesn't order them or anything it
turns out for such a small value you can
search that list for
duplication so you can reject D
duplicates faster than if you tried to
create a for Loop or any other kind of
uh fancy structure down here because
it's all goes in line in assembly Cod so
it just goes extremely fast so it can uh
creates this unique list of eight and
then when that's
exceeded the sketch transforms itself
into another data structure which is a
hash
set and it will go starting with a hash
set with log
K5 which is 32
entries in the hash set
and then if that once that gets
succeeded it transform itself into a
little larger hash set and gone all the
way up so if you started say with a log
case sketch of 14 it would get up to 11
and once that's succeeded finally it
promotes all the data to the actual hll
array so it's in a sense we're we're
caching values but we're caching them in
a very compact form so instead of 64
bits they're only 32 bits so it's
compressed but with 26 bits of
precision which is much much larger than
even 16 or 14 or whatever so uh that
itself gets rid of that early Spike
which went negative and the fact that we
are now to get rid of the The Flash
Spike we're using a mixture of
three different estimator
so we not we use a combination of the
Flaga hll estimator the poison estimator
and then we have a third degree
polinomial smoothing
function um that that's smooth over the
um over the values and basically a table
lookup so it's done extremely
fast
[Music]
um okay
so a sketch any of our sketches is not
just one
algorithm it's a lot of algorithms that
deal with specific issues of that
sketch now the result we get is is this
this is what we call our Pitchfork
plot which um is plus or
minus uh the green is one plus one
standard deviation or plus one rsse this
one's minus one then + two min-2 + three
minus three standard deviations and then
these grid lines are spaced at exact
multiples of the rsse so you can see the
plus one standard deviation
it it is ASM totic to exactly flattens
out at plus one standard deviation
that's good that says exactly what
theory predicts
that the error should
be
now there's another
little strange thing notice how it
exactly the experimental data act
exactly matches the plus three standard
deviation plus three
rsc's right on plus two right on plus
one the mean and median or smack on
zero - one looks okay minus two looks a
wee bit above minus
three is
short so it appears that the lower half
of this so-called Gan which is the
cross-section of this these are just
Contours is not the same size as the
upper part
now any guesses from the audience why
that's occurring
why would the lower half not be
gum okay
okay so now if I change instead of a log
log K of 16 which is 65,000 bins I'm
going to go down to log K4 which is
this is what it looks
like so now your your Pitchfork plot is
expanded it's actually stretched out in
in the this region and then shrunk down
here and part of the reason is that the
gine sketch of course is infinite in
both of its tails and actually goes
negative right but here we can only deal
with positive numbers so if you take a
gan curve and sque squeeze it up against
the zero a you know left axis it's got
to do something it's got to somehow
shrink and that's exactly what's going
on now what I don't know is what this
actual distribution
is but I would guess it's some sort of
multinomial I don't know you guys are
more expert than I but it's a it's a
real
phenomenon and we had to design our
estimators to accom accomodate for this
so we actually took samples of of the
data at all the different values of the
K of the sketch and then have the
estimator when you get your return if
you're asking for say like the plus one
standard deviation or minus one standard
it'll actually give you the correct
values based on on this distorted
curve very interesting phenomenon and
this brings up the fact that we give our
user users the possibility once they've
completed a sketch they can ask okay
what's what is my error at plus one
standard deviation what's my error at
minus one standard deviation and the
difference between those is your
confidence
interval and if it's plus minus one it's
confidence of like 68% if you do plus or
minus two it's about
95% so that gives the user a sense is
after I've done my sketch how good is
this
estimate and by giving the tools for
them to get the confidence interval they
get a good sense of whether it's any
good or not and by the way uh for our
Theta sketches which can do
intersections this holds true even
though if the sketch has gone through
multip multiple merges it's gone merges
with different size sketches and it's
gone through intersections or set
differences at the very end of all that
the user can and you know get plus or
minus what the uh standard you know what
the confidence interval interval is and
say okay how much should I lose through
this process and how how much can I
depend on
it person oh I just had a question about
this like gaussian the non- negative
gaussian like yeah isn't the typical
these are really big cardinality so
isn't your typical regime where like the
probability of returning a zero as your
estimate should be so small I would have
thought it like basically didn't matter
like I would assume the gaussian was so
far off shifted so far from zero because
AR isn't that your cardinality like one
million or something or that's what
you're trying to estimate right are you
asking about this or this I guess like I
guess yeah the next one like it looks
like is the only reason it's non
gaussian is because your error is so big
that you're actually pushing up against
sometimes returning
zero it's a different
distribution and fundamentally I don't
think the this even even for this what
looks giian yeah isn't really gaussian
yeah I guess what I'm saying though is
like if you're in a reasonable error
error regime I would assume re error
what does that mean I guess mean like if
you're if you have if your thing showed
up a million times it should never tell
you that it showed up zero times right
if you had a million unique items you
should never have say that you had zero
or one uni yeah right so in that Cas it
can't do
that and it doesn't it it just says it's
returning something with you
know so these lines again are at
multiples of well of excuse me of the
rsse for the perfect sketch okay and
this is because these are distorted
these are all shrunk right here and so
if you ask the sketch I want my what is
my error at minus two standard
deviations it'll give you this
number
okay okay I'll take it off it'll never
go to zero yeah yeah can't yeah yeah I
guess that's what I meant though is like
since it's never even close to zero like
it should be really close to gausian
distributed I would think like in most
but I we'll I'll take it offline okay
well the amount of distortion depends
not on um your stream size but on the
skage size and that parameter K so if K
is very low in this case so the it's
squished against the zero so for large
sketches when sketch has many many beIN
not just 16 like here but thousands then
it's almost G slightly distorted almost
indistinguishable well when someone
wants really small H sketch with crude
error then we need to account when when
the user asks for confidence interval we
need to account that it's actually
shifted a bit and squished
so it's not the same confidence Center
for large sketch with large number of
beans and the lesson here is you can't
you have to look at a characterization
like this you can't just say okay what's
the RSA of the sketch plus or minus that
and that's my confidence inter nope it's
not right
so so part of the message here is we've
taken the time to do these
characterizations to fully understand
how this thing behaves
even for very small sketches that's not
just small cardinality that's small
number of bins right as well as much
larger
sketches now here what I'm doing is I'm
testing to see if the question I'm doing
a query I want to get the plus one
standard deviation value and get the
minus one how closes it to what the
actual data is and so these dotted lines
represent that so if I if I say okay I
want the upper limit of three standard
deviations it'll give you this value and
if you want the lower limit of three
standard deviations for this particular
size sketch and so on it'll give you
that so yeah we test that
too now here I
compare um our hll sketch with the
Google uh HL Plus+ sketch it's it's a
good sketch there's no question about
it but when I do this kind of
characterization several several things
show up one is is and they brag about
this is they get more accuracy well they
do if you
notice here is like 512
cardinality and this thing really sort
of expands at
4,000 96 cardinality so factor of
eight uh so in this small region what
what's going on is that in the Zeta
sketch is they
compress the um sparse set before it's
fed into the hray they they compress
that to give them a little bit
more um cardinality before they finally
have to give up and and and throw it
into the sketch um but notice this big
spike is here that tells me that their
sparse set only has a cardinality uh or
excuse me a Precision of 17
bits in fact you can see it in here you
see these lines repeated but they're
very squeezed but if you actually zoom
in on this graph and see the separation
it represents the RSC of um log log K 17
sketch so this is all very predictable
and this is caused again because the
ultimate entropy of this whole sketch is
still lower than the entropy of the
incoming data right and so you'll have
these um quanti quantization errors that
that show up now the only reason this is
more raggedy than this one over here is
because it's so slow I lost patients and
stopped
after uh what's the third 2 to the 13th
which is 8,000 trials over here I went
all the way to a million trials so um
all right
so oh one other thing to notice notice
that the overall range here that plus
three standard deviations here is
smaller than plus three that's because
this is using the uh hip
estimator uh and also called the
Martingale
estimator um hi was uh developed by
Edith Cohen and Martin Gale
simultaneously was developed by Daniel
Ting um
independently and I asked Daniel one
time I said why did you call it the
Martingale well it turns out there's
some
obscure function in v statistics called
martingales and uh he used that as part
of his proof and so he called it the
Martingale but but anyway he said Edith
won this battle he said
uh calling it The Martin Gale is only
something a statistician would love
so
anyway okay so but after emerge um our
sketch looks more like this on the left
and you see now they they line up but
this still has the noise issue at U
during the sparse region yeah the Heap
does not survive merging so that's why
we switch to another one I'm sorry well
I I think you just skipped the point
that Heap or historic um inverse
probability estimator does not survive
merging right that's why you have to
switch if you that's correct if you use
mergin you have to use another one did
everybody get that the the hip estimator
does not survive
merge um and so you have have to go on
back to what we call our composite
estimators uh now so this work that that
the Google folks are doing here in this
compression costs something and so if
you squeeze a balloon at one end it pops
up in another and so the update
speed is much higher you see this huge
speed uh Spike here and the um severe
pant merge time so it's much much slower
in merging
sketches
um and even what we're showing is is our
plot this is uh our hl8 and then H 6 and
four but we've made dramatic
improvements on this lately that it even
reduces those by a factor of I don't
know at least two or
four okay so um a colleague that was
part of our group Kevin
Lang
um uh developed a new sketch I see I'm
running short on time uh called the CPC
sketch and it even beats hlll so no
hyper log log is not the best and
greatest um and you can see that a CPC
sketch with size log k11 is better has
uh Better Properties than the ENT than
the entropy in other words the ultimate
compression of an H&L for uh hll
sketch and the entropy line of hll is
this dotted orange line and the entropy
of the CPC sketch is is down here The
Zeta sketch is way up on top so low
lower towards the left corner is
better and in all truthful this however
he he paid a price in terms of the
serialization deserialization time
so yeah it's better better in accuracy
better in
size um okay and well it's a little
better in merge time but deserialization
serialization he had to pay the penalty
so
it's
okay um Theta sketches are most popular
sketch family it can do intersections
but
interestingly uh the interesting the
intersection error is not like Union uh
you actually lose error with
intersections but it's better than
trying to do the include exclude
relation by by quite a bit and the the
basic relation is the um relative error
for a Theta sketch intersection is the
square root of f which is the inverse of
the jard time 1 overun of K and this
gives the error curve which is certainly
higher than what the basic sketch is
which is this line here but still orders
of magnitude better than include
exclude so it can do intersections yeah
you lose some error but it's much better
than include
exclude and the tupple sketch was an
extension of the Theta sketch now here
what you have for all the bins of of an
HL sketch which is a Min m k sketch we
can attach an array of objects uh that
are associated with that that hash
value this makes things like this
customer
engagement kind of computation a trivial
which is complex otherwise um and this
if you start with say a 100 customers on
the first day of a month at the end of
the month you want to say how many of
those customers came back every
day well not very many of them but there
was one fanatic that liked your site and
came back to buy something or whatever
uh every all 30 days and there some set
of some set of those uh like 6 75 or so
that came back two days within that
period if you think about this problem
it's not trivial
um okay then Kevin also came up with a
frequent distinct Tuple
sketch um so simply it's multiple
dimensional but given a stream of say
like IP addresses and user IDs you can
find with one query what is the IP
addresses with the most
distinct um user IDs or the reverse find
the user IDs with the most distinct IP
addresses from the same sketch you don't
have to rebuild the
sketch you take your sketch and you
could do queries across any of the any
of the dimensions this
way now the frequent item SK also in the
in the literature
um it didn't have really a well-defined
error I mean it has a a prior sketch
error
um but we wanted to make it more useful
to to the engineer and so now uh you can
specify it'll return you specify no
false positives in your query then it
will return only the
selected uh group up
here if
uh with return with no false negatives
it's this next group and then the group
that's down in the noise below the noise
threshold you never return so
characterizing it this way is much
easier for them to
understand further insights merging
sketches with different K values is is a
very very important
property imagine you're a company and
You' created sketches of all your data
millions of sketches for all across
different dimensions and so forth then
one day you decide you
know I'd like to increase the accuracy
of our
sketches you've got years of History all
in sketches and you don't have the
original data so you can't rebuild
them if you can't merge across that
boundary of the lower K values and the
upper and the larger K values or more
more accurate sketches you're
screwed you essentially lose access to
that whole data so we provide the
capability emerging but with the merge
of a less accurate sketch with a more
accurate sketch you get accur basically
the accuracy of the less accurate but
over time if you only keep say two years
of history or five years over time that
history will roll off and then you will
have converted all of your data both old
and new to the to the new regime so in
the meantime you can still get
reasonable data from merging across that
boundary
um accuracy specification is critical
what accuracy can the user expect and
providing upper and lower bounds of a
confidence interal we found to be
extremely
valuable okay we also provide cross
language platform cap capabilities so
you can build your sketches
on uh
C++ transfer the binaries over to Java
and it can read them and process them so
also with python and numerical Precision
uh is is uh is something we also pay
attention
to okay uh I mentioned that mentioned
that I'm going the wrong
way okay so we have a large family of of
sketches in our library you might some
newer ones kernel density uh we have a
count men sketch these are all fairly
new liquid legance is a privacy sketch
we're we're experimenting with um but we
have
sampling of our up sketch which is from
Edith Cohen um proportion weighted
sampling sketch that is almost ready um
and these are I show you the different
languages that they're available
across there's a lot of sketch types
that we don't have we don't have much in
the graphs area we we're kind of weak in
in The Matrix and Vector sketches so um
if you folks have ideas about something
that would solve common problems
for um Matrix uh sketching Vector
sketching U or graph sketching we'd be
you know if you feel it solves a common
problem across a wide range of different
solutions um we'd be very interested in
talking to
you
please come talk to us we're interested
in your thinking and where you think
your your research is
going thank
[Applause]
you further
questions I think most of us in the
audience are like theorists who are far
away from kind concrete applications in
Industry I'm curious
um are there some you know from what
you've seen with data sketches being
used are there some like what are some
of the killer applications and are there
some that you think we theorists might
not know about what you want to make us
aware
of
um Char you can speak up on this too
we're we're playing with some new
Concepts and um we we really didn't have
we don't have anything like I said we
don't have anything in the graph
space um and
um experim experiment with privacy we've
recently built also by
um count men
sketch we find so the Theta sketch which
uh the name might not be familiar to
people but but that is it's essentially
a kmv sketch that's really widely used
because of the sets operations
flexibility that it gives um so you're
you're able to do a lot of filtering
over audiences um that brute forcing
just wouldn't allow you to do so that's
one application another application is
that
um merge ability is really important so
what we find is a lot of customers build
sketches on or it's a recent application
build sketches on a mobile device and
then like serial to make a small sketch
and then send that back elsewhere and
roll them all up
together but it's
certainly you know some of these
sketches we have found a bit of
difficulty as well like trying to
convince people to to take them
[Applause]
up I think we're dependent on you too
because clearly you you develop these
Advanced algorithms for a reason
um I guess there can be purely
mathematical reasons to do it but uh
hopefully you have some insight into how
this can be
used um and if you think of it's fairly
common
problem so two more applications as well
so the engagement histogram that was
showed a few slides back there's um a
bunch of media and advertising companies
back in London that are using that and
they really like the Theta and the
topple sketch for that reason there was
some work from Google a few years back
now where they combined uh data sketch
but instead of storing counters you
store a kmv in the
um in the payload and that for some
privacy type of application I don't know
exactly what it was um but
they got a lot of mileage out of that
type of data
structure I think graph analysis would
be interesting area I mean up till now
we haven't
seen a paper that was either
implementable or uh maybe made too many
assumptions too difficult to implement
but
um I think there a lot of applications
for graph
analysis for
sketching so I think you said one of the
areas we're interested in new sketches
and techniques is for like Matrix shaped
data linear algebra stuff is that the
one ones where you said you need new
sketch methods is that correct first of
all like linear algebra stuff you had
like a bunch of linear algebra bullet
points on your last slide
there
so oh we have an SVD sketch is that the
one you're referring to uh just in
general the like Matrix stuff stuff
let's say we we don't have much we have
um our singular value decomposition it's
approximate SVD
computation um there are probably better
algorithms out there to do that but it
was based on one
paper so the question I have broadly for
like just this column on the right of
like everything under matrices here is
it feels like a lot of these problems
like in the theory literature we at
least think we have implementable
algorithms
uh do you have a sense of like what
might be like the gap or what's missing
what are we not accounting for in our
current sketches in the theory
literature that aren't being able to
translate here for coar estimation or L
approximation or whatever else is on the
list here
um I wish I had better understanding of
the theoretical literature to answer
that
I I really depend on you guys okay who
who are browsing the theoretical
literature all the time
um is there any sort of like common faux
paw that the theoreticians think makes
an algorithm very implementable but like
impr practice doesn't translate anything
like that um broad
Strokes well if you implement for
instance a matrix sketch
or a graph
sketch make sure it works for small
graphs try I mean
seriously if it blows up because you're
using your in is too small that's a
problem right um so think about not just
in the limits but think about the low
values there was a question over here
just before the next question as well I
think one difficulty we have uh from our
colleague that's listening live
um explaining the error guarantees of
the Matrix
um Matrix estimation algorithms can be
quite challenging so for example
frequent
directions how you take that from yes
the algorithm is returning what it
promises to return to turning that into
an application where the user
understands it and wants to do something
with it is a challenge whereas
everything that we've showed you like
hll is very easy to understand what the
error means so something like an ostor
estimate you run the sketch and can now
like output a guarantee you are within
this percent of the optimal low rank
approximation that makes a big
difference okay cool thank you yeah
explaining explaining the error that's
useful
uh what was the what was the issue with
the um oh the was it the SVD sketch
that's that's specified in in The
covariance Matrix the errors in The
covariance
[Applause]
Matrix that's very difficult for an
engineer to sort of oh yeah obviously I
know how to translate that you know for
my customers um that's a bit obscure
so try and think of a practical
application for it translate whatever
your eror computation is into something
that an engineer can
understand I think we had another
question over here as well
yeah
uh
so I think I almost genical question for
is but for graphs and so I was thinking
about these graph sketches and I was
racking my brain about how implementable
they are and I love your question like
kind of make sure they work for small
graphs
um how small
like
okay I mean the solution may be trivial
it just made everything fall out and
well that's what I'm thinking like like
like in practice am I allowed to think
about um quote unquote sketches where
like kind of until the graph grows to a
certain moderate size say 500 nodes yeah
um I'm just maintaining the graph in an
uncompress in in a non- sketch form is
that legit or is it not
really that that could be I mean if it's
it's small anyway right so uh you may
not have to compress it if it's under
some certain size that's fine I mean
look what we do in
the
um for the sparse stages of a of an H&L
sketch we're basically taking a 64-bit
value actually 128 and compressing it
down to a 32bit value that is sufficient
for the ultimate yeah Sketch that it's
going into right and so we go through
several schemes of keeping that until we
finally have to go to the sketch itself
so similarly for matrices you may have a
simple form that you keep the Matrix in
until it gets to a certain size that you
really need to compress it or do
something more aggressive okay does that
make sense yeah absolutely uh thanks
yeah just to follow up maybe um maybe I
didn't fully understand so uh for the
graph sketching uh do you have an
application in mind or would you like
one because you know I have I have had
some thoughts on how to say do
connectivity with good constants um do
you have an application for graphs or is
this are you looking for a sketch or an
application here okay so in advertising
for example there's uh what's called
path
analysis so uh a user or site or ID or
whatever comes in through your network
and goes through various nodes or stages
throughout your processing and you'd
like to somehow track that um and right
now it's done very Brute Force there may
be more sophisticated ways of doing it
another example is funnel analysis and
so funnel analysis if you can imagine a
lot of people click on a site and they
look at a you know a new razor or
something like that and then they leave
and some other guy goes all the way
through the I want to purchase this goes
through the checkout
cart finally buys it you know that's at
the very tiny end of the funnel and
unfortunately the ratio between the
number of people that go all the way
through and actually purchase something
is orders of magnitude smaller than the
people that just enter the site and see
the ad and ignore it right so that
dynamic range is very Troublesome and we
haven't found a good way
to uh feed that to sketches because the
dynamic range is so huge I mean it's
like six orders of magnitude easily
but what will be the problem here do do
you want to how how to manage the orders
of
magnitude then do I understand correctly
that you're only interested in
ultimately recovering the successful
purchases the the users to understand at
each stage as they go through that
process how much fall off you have oh I
understand okay yeah I see it's
understanding each stage of that funnel
how you know you want to say how what
can I do to inent the customer to go to
the next stage right offer a sale a deal
or whatever that's very common in
advertising okay thank
you any other questions
yeah so this is slightly leading
question uh but in um in the literature
it's conventional to uh establish your
desired um your desired
accuracy which then uh gives you some
expression for the amount of memory
required um but in practice uh you have
a real system which has a memory budget
uh and so uh I've I have talked to
people who care about the the converse
situation where you express the budget
as a part as a part of the theorem and
want to know the like maximum available
accuracy which you say that's something
that you yeah absolutely a way of
casting it you prefer we absolutely we
have a specific method call on all all
of our sketches that says okay what is
the maximum size that this sketch can
grow to given some parameter okay that
yeah that's critically important for
precisely that
reason thanks given uh given Epsilon
what K I need or the other way around
given K like budget for the sketch what
Epsilon I can achieve something like
that for almost all sketch I think we
have conversion like that not sure you
can give it an epon I only care about
this accuracy what K do I need right so
you can go back back and forth so we
provide these tool functions and all of
our sketches to make it easy for the
engineers to use it does that make
sense yeah memory memory budgeting is
very
real any other questions and this is not
a complete lists you know I'm sure there
are a lot of this is very general kind
of
vague but there may be
applications even though we've heard
this week that um we haven't thought of
where something is
used quite frequently or has multiple
places of
[Applause]
application sorry we went over but
but we have again discussion
which let's
[Applause]
give